when I had my kids it was like
that changed everything well the things
you won't do for yourself you do for
your kids and are we protecting our
children the way that we never got to
have that protection right definitely
definitely I hired I hired um it's funny
my kids didn't know they had a security
guard at school I hired someone to be an
assistant PE instructor yeah just to be
there because people were trying to take
them off the schoolyard I had to find
clever ways to kind of make them feel
everything was normal but I needed to
know eyes were on them and not you know
and I was not going to take that chance
I mean your dad and Tommy like teamed up
against the paparazzi and when they're
going after you at The Viper Room and
like I just it's at a certain point
I so understand I get it dope with my
kids this is not okay they didn't sign
up for this yeah it's sad so hard I know
I know but you're gonna get through you
you got it you got it now I mean this is
this how did you get through it because
you raised these incredible boys you
have to be careful that social media and
everything and then there's that layer
I'm like oh I love having kids in this
day and age and maybe our whole lives
were the best
things for setting us up as parents we
just have to make sure that women know
how to make themselves safe from very
young girls
I also feel like
anything that you do
that might have put yourself out there
in a sexual way gives you also no
protection right or everything is fair
game no right to privacy yes and that I
probably wanted the attention when the
tapes were stolen and put out there that
are they I remember going to a
deposition and they had naked pictures
of me everywhere saying you like this
what kind of sexual positions do you
like and I was pregnant with Dylan and
Tommy and I just said we just have to
let this go the damage is done it's out
there and we're never going to be able
to stop it so Tommy just said you're
right let's just end it We're not gonna
fight this and I don't want one stupid
scent from this thing we've been offered
millions of dollars for this thing we're
like it's just dirty money it's bad
karma I can make my own way I'd rather
you know I'd rather do anything than
take money from that I think that
intention has and will continue to pay
off in your life and it isn't fair
because if you went through it anyway
why not benefit from it but I just think
the protection and your karma of your
intention is is such a good thing you
know and don't you love not knowing
what's next yeah every corner I say is a
turn is a chance for an opportunity
I'm like just wait something great is
coming around the corner and they're
like
yourself and the universe and everything
and you know the universe validates
goodness and excited for life I don't
fear what's coming up I'm excited about
what's coming up I will make what's
happening coming up a lot of because you
went through so much and you survived so
much you're strong I mean I I am strong
but they're I'm so strong
but also you've got to say something
that also I hadn't heard another woman
say which is you know I don't really
know exactly how to love someone that
isn't my kid's dad
I know that's hard isn't it it's
just that connection that you don't have
with anybody else and people may say
that they can get past it but I can't I
haven't been able to and that's okay I
don't even care if I'm alone the rest of
my life I've experienced really
wonderful loving moments and sometimes
things don't last forever for a reason
and it's it's okay it's fine it's okay
in the last year I spent alone I think
it's been the happiest year of my life
but I love this discovering of myself
and I just there's so many parallels
and I went I by the way I went um to the
opening night of Chicago I know you
didn't I didn't know that you were there
I've got your flowers and thank you so
much but I didn't know you were there
well it was probably better you had a
lot to concentrate on you don't need to
know anything other than what you need
to do I love the dedication I loved in
the documentary that you could really
see all the work that goes into that I
know I understand because I get it but
like no one will understand like how
much work goes into it and you nailed it
and I loved it you've opened yourself up
to this next chapter and one of my final
questions was going to be you know what
do you want to do next and so this woman
her name is Tara Watson she did this
tweet that went viral about how you
should join the cast of White Lotus yeah
I've heard that too
um have you heard about this I heard
about it I mean I can't get white I call
it white onion but anyways it's pink I
don't know what anyway I can't get it in
Canada because my HBO app doesn't work
because my Apple ID is American so I
can't get it there so I have to watch it
but I tried to watch it but I heard
everyone loves it and it's crazy and I
think I I mean I'm up for anything so
you haven't really seen it yet no okay
it's definitely one of I think I would
say the only way to describe it is a
masterpiece
really yes it's a masterpiece Mike White
who is writing and directing it it is a
masterpiece and each season is different
than the other there's a through line
with a woman named Jennifer Coolidge
that's who they're saying you need to be
a relative of hers she was the string
from one to two
um that's not a spoiler it is a
masterpiece and I now want to vote for
that too
I really do like I said something great
is just around the corner would you be
okay I don't know I don't know I mean I
just feel like this is this is a it's
such an interesting time I just kind of
want to see what I I would love to do
something like I said when I did
Broadway I just wanted to know what I
was capable of I didn't know if I could
sing if I could dance if I could act on
stage in front of her I just want to
push myself so I think that would be an
incredible Challenge and but like I said
I'm not a I'm not an ambitious person I
just I'm not either I hate the word
ambition yeah you know what I love I
survive an ambition I just love this
kind of you know romance and sensuality
and this kind of romantic kind of
lifestyle that I've you know activism
and everything so I don't really know
what's next but I don't I know I haven't
really had the opportunity to see what
I'm capable of on film yet it's been but
I got to do Broadway like my kids
in my closing night to see my kids in
the front row look at me with such Pride
I'd never seen that before when it comes
to you know my career because they're
like my dad's a rock star and my mom
rescues animals and you know some other
stuff
hahaha
I can tell they're so proud of you yeah
they're amazing and for the real you the
unfiltered mom that they know who is a
great woman and who does advocate for
animals and is talented and has been of
utter Fascination and desirability there
is a reason people are drawn to your
light and love you and I'm sure at
moments that's been such a heavy burden
and I'm sure that it's also right as
rain and true as anything has been that
there's a reason people are so obsessed
with you
which sounds utterly creepy and
complimentary at the same time but I
don't know whether to hug you or run out
the door
I love you I love you I think you're
fantastic and you know I've all people
are drawn to you too like I you're just
such this likable lovable person well
we've been able to mean some weird
ability to have longevity incredible
we're still here we're still here I'm
still here I cannot wait to see what you
do next this is a fertile opportune
redeeming uh meaningful uh earned
time for you are you gonna do more
movies
you have to if we could do one together
we could both be in White Lotus we could
um that would be funny I want you to be
a White Lotus I I would do we could be
sisters and White Lotus yeah
should we call Mike White maybe we
should call him oh that's funny I'm
telling you I have to say also why This
Woman's tweet has gone viral and why
everybody's jumped on the bandwagon is
because I think that show
um is becoming a franchise that might be
one of the most respected in this
industry and that's where people see you
wow who would have thought I would we
all would
it's true you are so loved and
appreciated thank you okay we're gonna
go but when we come back we are doing
rapid fire and boy does it get funny
we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign